Який рівень освіти забезпечують українські школи?
Наскільки добре вони готують підлітків
до дорослого життя порівняно з іншими країнами?
Щоби зрозуміти це, Україна вперше приєдналася
до міжнародного дослідження успішності школярів
PISA, яке проводиться раз на три роки.
Програму міжнародного оцінювання учнів PISA
з 2000-го року проводить Організація економічного співробітництва та розвитку,
яка об'єднує 36 найрозвиненіших країн світу.
Спершу дослідження проводили
лише серед держав-учасниць, щоб оцінити
рівень освіти та підвищити ефективність
своїх економік. Тепер разом із країнами-партнерами
у програмі аж 79 учасниць. Серед них і Україна.
У 2018-му PISA оцінювала рівень навичок
15-річних школярів у читанні, математиці
та природничих науках. Причому тести перевіряють
не знання формул чи правил, а вміння
аналізувати інформацію та вирішувати завдання
серед підлітків, які через 2-3 роки
вступлять у доросле життя.
За показником читацької компетенції -
здатності розуміти й аналізувати тексти -
українські учні набрали в середньому 466 балів.
Стільки ж отримала Туреччина.
Найближчими сусідами України за цим показником
стали Ізраїль та Люксембург.
Із пострадянських країн і водночас у межах Європи
найкраща - Естонія: аж 523 бали.
Для порівняння: в Німеччини - 498.
Найкращий показник - у китайських школярів: 555 балів,
найгірший - у філіппінських, які теж уперше
взяли участь в оцінюванні.
У математиці ситуація схожа:
українські учні в середньому здобули 453 бали,
німецькі - 500, американські - 478.
Лідером рейтингу з математики залишаються китайці.
У природничих науках школярі з України
отримали 469 балів, з Естонії - 530,
з Німеччини - 503 бали, а на першому місці -
ті ж учні китайських шкіл
із майже недосяжним рівнем у 590 балів.
Загалом, згідно з результатами дослідження,
шкільна успішність підлітків в Україні -
на одному рівні з Ізраїлем, Люксембургом,
Туреччиною, Словаччиною та Грецією.
У міжнародному порівнянні українські школярі
опинилися приблизно в середині списку.
Серед майже 80 держав-учасниць
Україна - 36-та з читання, 41-ша з математики
та 35-та з природничих наук.
Проте програма PISA дає оцінку знанням
відносно не всіх країн, а середнього показника
найрозвиненіших держав світу,
і тут бали України суттєво нижчі середнього рівня.
Водночас тести з читання показали, що
учнів-"середнячків" в Україні стільки ж,
як і в середньому в країнах OECP,
а от відмінників суттєво менше:
3% в Україні проти 9% у розвинених країнах.
Роботи з математики та природничих наук
свідчать про те, що поки навички
українських школярів не дотягують
до середнього рівня провідних економік.
Також дослідники опитали школярів
про умови їхнього життя, щоби встановити,
які фактори впливають на успішність дітей.
Тут ситуація краща: дівчатка показують
не гіршу успішність, ніж хлопчики;
діти з незаможних родин мають такий доступ
до якісної середньої освіти, як і заможні;
технічне оснащення, наявність вчителів у школах -
загалом середні в порівнянні з розвиненими країнами.
Окрім того, порівняння успішності учнів
та фінансування освіти показало, що Україна,
так само як і Хорватія та Білорусь, використовує
наявні кошти ефективніше, ніж багато інших країн.
Ще до оголошення звіту міністерка освіти України
Ганна Новосад заявила: результати дослідження
стануть для української влади "відправною точкою",
за допомогою якої в подальшому можна буде
вимірювати успіхи освітньої реформи.
Так само до програми ставляться й інші країни:
невтішні результати стають тривожним сигналом
про поступову втрату конкурентоспроможності
як із точки зору економіки, так і на ринку праці.
Наприклад, на початку 2000-х PISA
розміщувала Німеччину наприкінці своїх рейтингів.
Шкільна система Німеччини, за даними дослідників,
погано забезпечувала рівність шансів
на хорошу освіту й успішну реалізацію в дорослому житті,
особливо для дітей із соціально незахищених
та мігрантських родин.
У результаті розпочатих реформ за 10 років
Німеччина скоротила розрив успішності
між учнями з різних соціальних умов на 50%.
Окрім того, ФРН послідовно покращує свої позиції,
зокрема, з природничих наук.
Із 20-го місця в переліку 32-х у 2000-му році нині
вона піднялася на 12-ту позицію з 79-ти.